Cobra Kai is moving to Netflix for its
third season continuing to settle the
score between Karate Kid Rivals Johnny
Lawrence and Daniel laruso let's head
into the dojo and meditate on the most
clever and easy to miss references and
Easter eggs hiding in the series first
two seasons The Karate Kid is a classic
movie of the 1980s beyond the main story
of a spirited Underdog overcoming the
odds to Vanquish his better prepared
opponent there's a strong through line
of class Warfare as in other Classics
from the era like pretty and pink or
some kind of wonderful the rich kids are
needlessly and endlessly cruel to the
kids from families with less money true
to form Johnny comes from money and
lives in a nice area and he's harsh to
and dismissive of Daniel right away
because this new kid in town and Son of
a single mother lives in a small
inexpensive apartment in the less
exclusive town of R when Cobra Kai picks
up the story more than 30 years on the
situation has reversed Daniel owns a
chain of car dealerships and has a lot
of money in the bank Johnny on the other
hand is divorced barely getting by and
lives in a tiny non-descript apartment
building in a not fancy neighborhood
viewers may not notice that Johnny's
complex is called R Heights meaning he
lives almost exactly where Daniel once
did at the end of the 1984 classic
Johnny the villain of the pce ends the
big match face down on a gym mat
thoroughly defeated by Daniel at the all
Valley karate tournament to set up how
Cobra Kai examines the world of
California dojo karate from the point of
view of Johnny it opens up with a shot
to let the world know exactly where it's
starting from philosophically speaking
with Johnny fa down on a messy bed
beaten not by Daniel but by the harsh
travails of a disappointing life over
the past 30 years the fate of one Cobra
Kai character is tragic and sad but it
also provided the series writers with a
chance to make an extremely subtle nod
to a famous line from the original
Karate Kid movie and which makes it
ghoulishly prophetic in the process it
was a real coup for Cobra Kai to get
actor Rob Garrison to make an appearance
on the show in 2019 seeing as how he'd
retired from acting and had only
appeared in one other project in nearly
25 years he reprised his role as Tommy
one of Johnny Lawrence's Cobra Kai
friends and fellow bullies from The
Karate Kid in Cobra Kai Tommy is dying
and he has one last day of drinking
riding motorcycles and camping with his
friends before passing away in his sleep
that at least completed his character's
unresolved Arc after so many years the
last viewers see of Tommy is when
lifeless corpse is zipped into a body
bag that's a reference to the first
Karate Kid when Johnny fights in the
climactic All Valley karate tournament
when Tommy roots on his compatriot who
is Thoroughly putting a beat down on
Daniel so you okay can you go on get a
body bag
yeah sadly the real life Garrison died
just a few months after his cobrai
appearance making it extra touching that
he returned to the franchise decades
later for such a silly and yes morbid
joke in the first season episode of
Cobra Kai Never Dies Daniel laruso makes
breakfast for his kids proudly and
enthusiastically whipping up a sugary
concoction of batter fruit and chocolate
chips he calls Banana Rama pancakes
that's a cute bit of goofy dad word
playay but it also alludes to a music
cue from the first Karate Kid movie the
movie came out in 1984 during the brief
period of time when English vocal group
bananama was extremely popular in the
United States one of the Trio's biggest
was cruel summer which is also a song
that soundtracks Daniel's first bicycle
ride to his new school in the Karate Kid
the synth pop classic doesn't actually
appear on the film's official soundtrack
so that's an Easter egg just for fans
extremely familiar with the movie itself
the song is so associated with The
Karate Kid that a cover of the tune
showed up in a second season episode of
Cobra Kai during a similar establishing
shot of a bustling day at school the
karate kids spawned a hefty film and
television Universe many of the entries
were largely forgotten by the time the
first season of Cobra Kai reached a
paying audience on YouTube such as the
ill-fated 1994 reboot starring Hillary
Swank the 2010 remake starring Jaden
Smith and Jackie Chan and the 1989
animated The Karate Kid television
series but the circumstances of Cobra
Kai are to be interpreted to their
logical but Extreme end there's another
film series that could be considered a
part of The Karate Kid extended Universe
in Cobra Kai Johnny Lawrence is divorced
from his former wife Shannon the mother
of his son Robby in the 2010 movie Hot
Tub Time Machine which is partially set
in the 1980s Cobra kiar William zabka
plays a guy named Rick and Diora beard
plays his wife beard portrays Shannon on
COBRA Kai implying that they're the same
couple and that things obviously ended
badly at some point oh really one more
bet no Ricky come on you said one more
and then you'd be done I also said to
shut the up remember that PBO the second
to last episode of season 2 of Cobra Kai
includes the unlikely sight of longtime
enemies Johnny and Daniel on a double
date together albeit reluctantly they do
have a bit of fun when they recount
their long and violent rivalry they also
pinpoint the weird moment when it might
have all began you SC a blueberry pie on
my shirt that's CU you put it on my
chair first he's leaving out the
details speaking of leaving out the
details this inciting Act of aggression
May strike even the biggest karate kid
fans as unfamiliar and surprisingly
there's a good reason for that Johnny
and Daniel beginning a war over
blueberry pie was scripted but didn't
make it into the Final Cut of the movie
in 2012 Karate Kid director John aalson
posted a bunch of behind the-scenes
footage to YouTube including one of
actors Ralph machio and William zabka
rehearsing a scene of Daniel and Johnny
attempting to humiliate each other with
the help of a little dessert you take
his
pie and you get up many of the major
cast members of the original The Karate
Kid movies from the the 1980s show up
for at least a cursory Cameo at some
point in the first two seasons of Cobra
Kai Martin Cove even shows up as the
presumed dead crease to bother and
motivate Johnny and Randy Handler recurs
as Daniel's mother Lucille laruso one
notable Omission at least in the first
two seasons Elizabeth Shu and her
character Ali Mills is nowhere to be
found apparently not ready to reprise
her role as a love interest and source
of tension between her ex-boyfriend
Johnny and his rival Daniel last
mentioned is having left Daniel for a
UCLA football player in the Karate Kid
Part Two Alli may not appear in the
first two seasons of Cobra Kai but her
presence is strongly felt throughout
Daniel and Johnny explain and dissect
their love triangle from long ago and
Daniel lets slip that Ally became a
pediatric surgeon and moved to Denver
with her oncologist husband all of which
she ascertained from a little Facebook
snooping one of the final shots of
season 2 shows the screen of Johnny's
angrily discarded phone displaying a
friend request from one Aly mil
schwarber shoe does appear briefly on
camera in the form of a photo taken in
the 80s it sits in the trophy case at
Johnny's old high school for some reason
Los Angeles is a massive City with
countless entertainment options and yet
the young people of The Karate Kid and
kraai universe seemed to only ever
patronize one family entertainment
establishment both back in the 80s and
today in the Karate Kid Daniel takes
Ally on a sweet and innocent first date
to golf and stuff an actual put putt
course and gaming arcade located in
Norwalk California there they engage in
wholesome activities like air hockey
bumper boats bumper cars and drinking
soda pop viewers learn from Cobra Kai
that Johnny also took allly on their
first date to golf and stuff kicking off
their 2-year romance in high school
making it extra harsh in retrospect that
Ally and Daniel went there too golfing
stuff then shows up for real when karate
student Miguel takes out Daniel's
daughter Samantha for an evening of fun
the ninth episode of the first season of
Cobra raai is titled different but same
a clue into how the episode finds once
and again enemies Johnny and Daniel
reconnecting over the many things they
turned out to have in common look good
together different but same for example
a bout of beer soaked reminiscing
reveals that both men aren't totally
over Ali Mills who Daniel dated in high
school after she broke up with Johnny
and who Johnny still thinks that Daniel
moved in on similarly different but same
is how in the previous this episode
molting Miguel a cobra Kai trainee spies
Johnny's son Robbie getting along a
little too well with his girlfriend Sam
who also happens to be Daniel's daughter
in that same episode a group led by
Daniel's n do well cousin sets Johnny's
car on fire and he blames Daniel what
could be a very violent situation is
ultimately diffused by Daniel's wife
Amanda who suggests her husband hand
over free of charge a car of Johnny
selection from one of the many Lots
owned by by their laruso Auto Group
thought you sold Porsches yeah right in
your dreams Daniel escorts Johnny to a
dealership full of selections and
instructs choose that's the same simple
line delivered in the same simple way
that Mr Miyagi offered Daniel a car as a
birthday present back in the Karate Kid
in the years since the events of the
original Karate Kid movies took place
Daniel laruso has done quite well for
himself he's married to Amanda with two
kids Samantha and Anthony and he owns an
operat laruso Auto Group a successful
chain of suburban Los Angeles car
dealerships but he hasn't completely
forgotten karate which was an important
and formative part of his youth the
former all Valley karate champion uses
the martial art as a recurring bid in TV
commercials for his car lots literally
karate chopping high prices and
promising to kick the competition these
air on local television all the time
where the jealous and resentful Johnny
Lawrence sees them and finds them to be
extremely corny he isn't wrong however
Johnny soon comes to realize the power
and importance of branding when he makes
a TV commercial for his new and improved
Cobra Kai Dojo well he doesn't do it
he's proudly not the least bit techsavvy
but he recruits karate student Aisha
Robinson to put the spot together he
does have one suggestion to place the
Cobra Kai logo at the end rendered in
prome so that it impressively pops off
the screen we don't see the finished
result but we have a good idea of what
Johnny's getting at where have Cobra Kai
viewers previously seen a chrome Cobra
Kai logo that pops off the screen at the
end of every episode of Cobra Kai That's
where check out one of our newest videos
right here plus even more Looper videos
about your favorite movies and TV shows
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the Bell so you don't
miss a single
one